that is seven o'clock good to see you
this morning a government still in the
firing line over those poor conditions
at migrant processing centers was yet
another damning report into police
culture two big stories to get into on
today's show the transport secretary
Mark Harper plus the shadow Health
secretary was streeting it is Wednesday
the 2nd of November
vetting failures how hundreds or perhaps
thousands of bad apples could be working
in the police force we hear from one
woman about her own harrowing experience
they said you know they'd rip the
piercing out of my ear and then they
said oh let's see if she's got any more
a warning from the prison officers Union
of potential riots here at the manston
migrant processing center as a new
report reveals hundreds of children
housed in hotels have gone missing
Sky news reports from the trenches on
the road to Harrison as the former prime
minister Boris Johnson tells us he
doesn't believe that Russia will use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine
it's like the first world war down here
it's very compact claustrophobic really
people sleep in in holes in the walls
you fear that he could use a tactical
Nuclear I don't I don't think he I don't
think he will I think he'd be crazy to
to do so
calls to quit as pressure grows on Matt
Hancock over his decision to head to the
Jungle he reveals why he's chosen to go
aerate sirens sound in South Korea after
North Korea fires several missiles after
a series of previous tests ordered by
its leader Kim Jong-un
also ahead on the program
oil machine a new film delves into our
destructive relationship with the fossil
fuel I'll be speaking to an activist who
watched on the film at half past night
and do you remember this
choose life choose a job choose a career
you can now choose to relive the iconic
90s hit Trainspotting at this time live
on stage I'll be speaking to the actor
director behind it at quarter to ten
foreign
there is a warning that hundreds if not
thousands of corrupt police officers
could be serving in forces in England
and Wales from a watchdog that's
condemned police vetting standards his
Majesty's inspectorate of constabulary
and Fire and Rescue Services looked at
eight forces in a review ordered after
the murder of Sarah everard by former
officer Wayne cousins this guy's Becky
Cottrell has the detail just a warning
her report does contain descriptions of
incidents that some may find distressing
what you're about to hear is police
officers discussing a woman who's just
been strip searched
back in 2013 koshkadoff says she tried
to help a teenage boy during a stop and
search by police but when her
intervention landed her in a Cell she
says female officers assaulted her
they were you know grabbing at my
breasts they stuck their hands between
my legs they said um you know they'd rip
the piercing out of my
um ear and then they said oh let's see
if she's got any more and they stuck
their hand between my legs last year
koshka received compensation and an
apology from the Metropolitan Police for
the sexist and derogatory language of
the officers but a damning new report
has found that misogyny and predatory
behavior are prevalent across forces the
review team also looked at hundreds of
files on the vetting of officers there
were a significant number where we
thought that somebody just shouldn't
have been employed or if they were going
to be employed there should have been a
pattern of supervision of them greater
than normal that just wasn't happening I
think we're safe to say that over the
last couple of years the police have
employed hundreds of people that we
think they shouldn't have done the
potential scale of the problem raises
serious concerns about Public Safety
after Sarah everod's murder
her killer Wayne cousins a serving
member of the Metropolitan Police had
been part of a WhatsApp group with other
officers who sent messages described as
repulsive and misogynistic it has to be
not just a type but a wave of change it
has to be people feeling they can come
forward report things and and then when
that when that is proved and that person
has proved to have done that that
wrongdoing they need to be gone as
quickly as possible and that process is
too slow the Met says they welcome the
report and will consider opportunities
for learning and Improvement adding
being ruthless in reading the Met of
those who corrupt our integrity is
Central to commissioner Mark rowley's
vision of Reform we are setting clear
expectations of behavior and are
developing data and Technology to
identify those who are not fit to serve
we will succeed with the vast majority
of our honest and dedicated officers and
staff
change is needed now as the review's
leader put it officers shouldn't just
represent Society they need to represent
the best of it it seems like we're a
long way off that Becky Cottrell Sky
News
and at half past eight I'll be speaking
to the woman that you just saw in
Becky's report to yourself was subjected
to a degrading strip search by police
half past day from that
but as you can see I am joined now in
the studio by the transport secretary
Mark Harper Mr Robert lovely to have you
in here um but but shall we start with
this does this deeply damning uh report
from the Police Inspector incredibly
worrying not least of course because of
Sarah everard and and repeated instances
of misogyny within the police force what
needs to happen for the police to get
their house in order well look first of
all I think it's worth remembering this
report was commissioned by pretty Patel
when she was home secretary in the wake
of the Sarah everard absolute murder
um and it does contain a very worrying
number of findings
um and I think it's a real wake-up call
for chief constables across the country
so I mean what the government hopes is
that those Chief constables uh and the
you know the National Police Chiefs
Council will look at this report and
every force will look at their practices
how they recruit officers you know how
they run their disciplinary processes
and make the necessary changes to
improve standards so the public have the
confidence in the police force that that
is the key point isn't it when you have
the inspector it's saying that there are
hundreds perhaps thousands of bad apples
and we're being very mild to the
language of their bad apples
it seems almost impossible to me that
you can restore confidence in the police
until that situation is entirely
resolved well I think the first thing is
yes the report is has a number of
concerning findings but on the other
hand the positive thing is it's much
better that we understand the scale of
the challenge we understand what the
problems are that's the first thing you
have to do to be able to fix them and
the Home Secretary has made it very
clear that this is an important priority
for her it's an important priority for
government but but ultimately this is up
to Chief constables and they've now got
the information in front of them and the
government will expect them to act on
the the recommendations and the findings
of the report and the government will do
what it can to support them in
delivering that so the public can have
the confidence in the police force that
they need indeed it would run us to have
the transport secretary and then not
talk about your brief we will do that
just a little later in the interview but
I think we need to start with with
manston currently what is the situation
in there the latest on numbers do we
have an idea it was it was above 4000
which is at the very least two to three
times the capacity for this facility
Well look as you know the immigration
Minister Robert generic visited the site
uh with the local Member of Parliament
sir Roger Gale at the weekend and I know
it's a priority now for uh for him and
for the Home Secretary to enable us to
get uh migrants out of that site you
know faster than they're arriving to
reduce the pressure
um that has started to happen but of
course I think it's reasonable to say
it's not going to happen overnight I
mean I've been an immigration minister
in the past
um there are no Simple Solutions here
they're very difficult but the
government is putting the steps in place
to procure more accommodation
um you know to start work or to continue
working with our partners in France to
reduce the numbers that are coming and
over time we'll be able to reduce the
numbers
uh in in that camp to what they should
be and in fact it was only relatively
few weeks ago that it was working very
well
um and it's it's when you say that you
said that the inspection report
identified problems dating back as far
as far as July did say that the camp was
was functional at that point it clearly
isn't functional at the moment when the
latest development is the prison
Officers Association uh coming out and
suggesting that we could be close to
riots within there because of the
conditions that that rather speaks to a
desperate need to improve the Staffing
numbers inside manston right now well I
think manston's not designed as a
large-scale Holding Center
but it's designed to have people there
for a short period of time before
they're then moved into other
accommodations so that's what the
immigration minister is focused on I
think progress has started to be made on
that but it's clearly not going to be
dealt with overnight but it is it is a
it's the number one priority for for the
home office uh and it's a very
significant priority for the government
and I've talked to both the Home
Secretary and the immigration Minister
about it and I know they're very focused
on making progress on a daily basis as
you mentioned you yourself were an
immigration Minister back 2013 2014
that's right yeah yeah
um you understand the the necessity to
use temperate language when talking
around this issue was it right that
swella bravaman described the situation
as an invasion on our South Coast well
look I think it's important for the
public that because the Public's very
concerned about this issue and actually
has been for for many years I think it's
very important that the Home Secretary
demonstrates to the public that she
understands the scale of the problem so
that the public have the confidence that
she and the immigration Minister are
going to put the appropriate focus on
dealing with it uh and you know there
are no easy solutions here but we can
deal with it when I was immigration
Minister we had a huge problem with
people coming in trucks
with respect we're talking about the
language here Mr Harper would you have
used the phrase an invasion on the south
course well look in the immediate
aftermath of a petrol bomb attack on a
margin or nerve facility every
politician chooses to express themselves
in in the way that they do and I think
what was important the Home Secretary
was trying to convey to the House of
Commons that she understood the scale of
the challenge so the people at home who
are concerned about this issue know
that it's an important priority for her
and for the home office to deal with
this problem and I think actually the
public understanding that politicians
get that this is a real problem indeed
actually can help people feel reassured
that someone gets the problem and is
focused on dealing with it but it's
actually a good thing I I I get that but
again inflammatory language such as that
has been seen as an incitement to
Violence by people within your own party
you yourself back when you were an
immigration Minister were responsible
for those go home Vans and you remember
yourself I'm sure very very well the
criticism that you received at the time
from people who had computers refugees
from people who had come here as
economic migrants because of the the
tone that was struck does the
conservative party sometimes or the
right of the conservative party
sometimes of a problem with the language
it it deploys clearly reaching out to
certain parts of the community like this
I mean you were you were pilloried for
this well some people criticize me but I
mean they're very clear they're about
whether the people who are here
illegally or not I'm very clear our
country welcomes people who come here
legally we provide safe refuge for
people fleeing from a war and
persecution you know we've had a
fantastic response from both the
government and the public for people
fleeing from the war in Ukraine you know
we've got 140 000 people here
there are no safe routes here unless
you're from Hong Kong Ukraine uh or
indeed Afghanistan the only way that
people can get healers across the
channel as well but with respect people
who are in France are in a safe country
and we've always been clear that people
should seek asylum in the first safe
country
people have to listen to people who
believe they don't have to listen people
who are in France are safe they're not
fleeing from France
um so they're actually in a safe place
and we've been clear and I was very
encouraged last week the Prime Minister
had an introductory call with President
mackerel and I think they agreed that
both of our countries would continue to
work together and would step up or
cooperation because we're only going to
deal with this issue if we work closely
with our partners in France do you think
France is doing enough well I think I
think both of both countries Britain and
France could both do more so what we
need to do is work with the French they
do a lot already
we provide resources to help them and of
course people will know that our border
controls in France are actually
physically located in France and we've
always worked in close partnership with
French authorities do we think they
could do more yes we could do more as
well and it's about improving that
partnership and that's why that
conversation with the Prime Minister and
the president were so welcome let's
let's hope that bears fruit before we
just get on to transport and on taxation
treasury sources yesterday appear to
confirm that we are about to see tax
Rises across the board is that your
understanding well look the Prime
Minister and the chancellor have both
been clear of the Autumn statement that
we've obviously got to set out a very
credible fiscal plan we are going to
have to make difficult decisions it
would be quite wrong for me to speculate
on those so I'm not going to go beyond
what either the prime minister or the
chances have said already but look we
are going to have make difficult
decisions it's important if we produce
an Autumn statement that is credible
that will mean that we Bear Down on
inflation more quickly and why that
matters to people listening to this
program is that means we'll be able to
have inflation uh interest rates lower
than they would otherwise be which
obviously directly feeds through into
people's mortgages so a credible plan is
going to require tough decisions but
obviously the chance will lay out both
sides of the Ledger as it were the tax
measures and spending measures in one
place on the 17th of November let's go
to your brief then shall we and a big
decision that you have to make it
regards High Speed 2 and the northern
Powerhouse Rail Link can you confirm
whether or not you will be upholding
what Liz trust promised at the
Conservative Party Conference that you
will be building that High Speed Line
infill from Manchester to Leeds via
Bradford so so two things first of all
on the high speed 2 because there were
various stories that popped up at the
weekend the government remains committed
to delivering High Speed 2 on time and
within budget very specifically on that
High Speed Line between Manchester and
Leeds with that station
well I think it's fair to say as things
that the former prime minister said
right Rishi sunat made it clear when you
became prime minister that for all the
best motives a number of mistakes were
made and he was elected as prime
minister in part to fix them so so we're
going back to our 2019 Manifesto looking
at the commits we made we have got a
commitment to make sure we can get
high-speed trains to Leeds
um and what we're doing in my department
and what I've been briefed on is we're
looking at all of the options that are
available to do that and I will and I
will be hasn't been taken no I will be
looking at all of the options to do that
in light of the decisions we take in the
Autumn statement and then we'll be
setting out our plans in due course but
you can understand the levels and I've
only of course been in this job for a
week so I've got a you know we've got to
look at this properly they're big
decisions we're very committed to
delivering you know what's in the
integrated rail plan and there are a
number of options for how we deliver
high-speed services to leads and that's
what I'm looking at those options and
decisions will be taken in due course
indeed so it sounds at least that there
is a decision pending on that but
another promise that that Les trust made
regards the Sheffield Bradford dog sorry
Doncaster Sheffield airport perfectly
good airport that as things stand is now
going to go entirely to waste that
coupled with that High Speed Line could
turn that part of the country into a
Powerhouse it is it is it possible that
you and your role as transport secretary
will look again at Doncaster Sheffield
well look Doncaster Sheffield is also
owned by a a private company and they
turned down probably they turn down
public money they've they've um they've
had some of offer of support from from
local authorities and I know they're
looking at some bids that have been made
for the airport
um you know that's a decision for them I
know my predecessor and indeed I've
asked the aviation minister to continue
working both with the company to
encourage them to look at those bids
seriously and also you know I've spoken
to local members of parliament and
Aviation Minister will continue to
encourage them to look at constructive
solutions for that airport can we
conclude our discussion this morning and
by referring to your former conservative
party colleague Matt Hancock I just want
to to read you this quote
um from the deputy chairman of his local
conservative Association I'm looking
forward to him eating a kangaroo's penis
quote me you can quote me on that Andy
we we certainly have will you be looking
forward to watching Mr Hancock eating
kangaroo penis no I'm saying this on
television
well I'm not going to say it on
television look on this situation I
think as a former Chief whip I very much
support the decision that Chief whip has
taken she's members of parliament's
first responsibility when Parliament is
sitting it is to serve their
constituents and the chief witness more
than that he was the health secretary
during the covert pandemic and the
covert inquiry is about to start it is a
complete delegation of his
responsibilities isn't it to go away and
Men surround in the jungle a couple of
weeks the chief whips made the position
clear which is he's made a decision the
the going on I'm a celebrity is not
compatible with doing your job properly
as a member of parliament which is why
the Whip's been taken away and as a
former Chief whip I completely support
those decisions taken by my successor
would you support him standing down as
an MP well look he's now he now
currently doesn't have the conservative
whip so he's sitting as an independent
Member of Parliament what he chooses to
do in the future is a matter of him the
chief whips made the position of the
conservative party very clear which is
members of parliament should focus on
doing their job serving their
constituents in their constituencies and
in the House of Commons I would bet that
if the tables returned to this was a
labor politician you would be calling
for there to be a by-election over this
well decisions about whether people
stand at the future election for them
but the chief whips made it very clear
it's not acceptable for conservative
members of parliament to go on Celebrity
television programs when parliament's
sitting our job is to represent our
constituents in our constituencies and
in the House of Commons that position is
very clear I think my colleague will
have looked at that signal from the
chief Whip and the Prime Minister about
what the appropriate behavior is and I'm
sure the lessons will be learned by my
colleagues will you be like me assigning
the number to nominate him for Bush
tracker trials to your speed dial well I
think as that will remain between me and
my phone I think
cover thanks very much thanks very much
uh no much more on that interview a
little bit later in the program but two
Sudanese teenagers who say that they
were held at the Madison processing
center in Kent have described sleeping
on the floor and soaking wet clothing
they were speaking to Sky News as
pressure grows on the home office and
indeed the Home Secretary about
overcrowding and unhealthy conditions
and the prison officers Union is warning
of potential rights unless things
improve
tensions arise and the populations
getting bigger and bigger there's
there's nowhere to move these people
onto I think that eventually we'll see a
serious uh serious breakdown in public
order what does that mean potentially
your riot
guys Matthew Thompson is outside the
center for us this morning Matthew just
take us in a little bit more detail
through the concerns of the prison
Officers Association because they are
legion and they are pretty significant
they're extraordinarily significant the
fact that we're even talking about
potential riots at a migration
processing center like the one here in
Manson is extraordinarily serious and
the reason they are making claims like
that is because there is serious
overcrowding at the center the center as
you alluded to when you were speaking to
the minister a moment ago was only set
up to process something like 1 600
migrants at a time and even then to have
them there for no more than 24 hours
what we know has been happening in in
recent weeks is that there have been up
to 4 000 migrants there are some of them
staying for weeks and the conditions as
you might imagine are completely
unsupportable there is serious
overcrowding there are concerns about
sanitary nature of it there have been
reports of disease spreading and all
sorts of things so something needs to be
done the home office assures us that
substantial numbers are being moved on
we don't quite know how many at the
moment have been left have been exited
something like in the hundreds but
clearly many more hundreds thousands
even remain in there and something
urgently needs to be done about it
certainly does Matthew thanks very much
indeed
uh one imagines the situation in manston
will be coming up at pmqs it is of
course Rishi sunax first full week as
prime minister just a reminder that the
event is taking place at midday today
Sky News as always we'll have full live
coverage here on the Telly or on your
app
and let's take you through the morning's
papers and guess where a lot of them are
focusing their attention here's the
Metro it describes the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock as king of the
bungle after his decision to fly to
Australia to appear on I'm a celebrity
whilst Parliament is in session and the
coveted inquiry is underway
in an interview with the son Mr Hancock
insists that he knows what he's doing he
hasn't lost his marbles
here's the guardian it reports that the
government has drawn up emergency plans
for how to deal with winter blackouts
that could last for a week
the eye it carries predictions that
householders could soon be paying an
additional 880 pounds a year towards
their mortgages
reports of massive profits for oil firms
like BP Exxon Mobil and Saudi aramco is
promoting pressure for them to do more
to assist people with the cost of living
that's according to the ft
still to come on the program this
morning
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
has said that we are Putin would be
crazy to use nuclear weapons in Ukraine
I'll be asking the former head of the
British Army's chemical weapons unit
also later this summer a former Chief
immigration officer Kevin Saunders will
be giving us his take on what's
happening at the manston micro
processing center
and then just after eight I'll be joined
in the studio by Shadow Health secretary
from the shadow Health Secretary of
laborers at West Street
now South Korea's military have
confirmed the launch of a ballistic
missile by North Korea our Asia
correspondent Helen and Smith can tell
us just a little bit more at morning
Helena I mean there's a pattern of
behavior here we've been hearing quite a
lot of reports like this of late
yeah that's absolutely right the South
Korean military confirmed that 10
missiles were launched by the North
Koreans and crucially a couple were
launched in sort of South Southeast
Direction which is reasonably unusual
and one in particular
um actually landed closer to the South
Korean Coast than any missile has landed
in the history of tensions between these
two countries since they were divided in
the late 40s that one missile in
particular that landed close to the
South Korean Coast it actually landed
south of what's being called the north
limit line it's essentially sort of de
facto Maritime borders of disputed
Maritime border really between the two
countries and it was close enough
um the air raid sirens started sounding
on the island of oolong which is off the
South Korean coast and people that had
to take shelter for a short period of
time now the North Koreans for their
part they say they're saying that these
launches are necessary and part of what
they see as a provocation from the South
Koreans in Alliance with the Americans
there is currently big joint combined
military drills going on between those
two countries that the North Koreans see
is very provocative but as you say part
of a bigger picture more missile tests
this year than at any time since Kim
Jong-un has come to power the real
concern is whether they move on to
undertake a full nuclear test that will
be a much greater ramping up of what are
already escalating tensions certainly
would be Palin on many thanks
now South Korea is a prime minister
handak Sue has said the police must
explain their response to emergency
calls and hours before a Halloween party
Crush killed more than 150 people in
Seoul transcripts show that emergency
services received at least 11 calls in
the hours before the crash with callers
pleading for help but police only
responded four times and it's not clear
what safety measures they took on
arrival the National Police Commissioner
acknowledged crowd control that the
scene was inadequate
and has promised a thorough
investigation
a couple of the today's other headlines
now and the government has reportedly
tested emergency plans to cope with
blackouts lasting up to seven days this
winter the guardian says there's a
reasonable worst case scenario of
week-long outages due to strained energy
supplies a government spokesman told Sky
News they're preparing for all
possibilities no matter how unlikely
they are
Iranian University students are pressing
on with sit-down strikes and other
demonstrations despite an increasingly
bloody Crackdown Iran has seen some of
its biggest protests since the 1979
Revolution sparked by the death of young
women Masa and Minnie who'd been
arrested Iran's morality police one
thousand detained protesters are soon to
go on trial
poor sleep patterns could increase the
risk of developing glaucoma a large
study published by the Journal bmj open
found that too little and indeed too
much sleep can make a person more prone
to the eye disease as well as snoring
Israel's Benjamin Netanyahu could be
returning to power after the fifth
election in four years let's bring in
our Middle East correspondent Aleister
bunker with the latest uh from Jerusalem
so you were suggesting yesterday
Alastair the exit polls are are pretty
accurate where are we in terms of
counting how soon before we we actually
know the results
well first Neil good morning and on the
exit polls they put Benjamin Netanyahu
on between 61 and 62 seats in the
knesset when the exit polls came out uh
late last night now that would give him
a very slim majority there's 120 seats
in the knesset the Israeli Parliament so
you need 61 or above to get that
majority the counting is still going on
and it is roughly in line with what
those exit polls predicted however it
could be there are indications that
actually Netanyahu could do far better
than that and not just win a victory but
win a decisive uh Victory it would be a
remarkable comeback for a man who is
Israel's longest serving leader it would
be his sixth term as prime minister and
all of this against a backdrop of
corruption and fraud trials which he has
been undergoing over the last year or so
so it does look like it has been a very
good night for benign Netanyahu we won't
know the final results until uh tomorrow
perhaps even Friday Friday morning and
then comes the task of building a
coalition and it'll be really
interesting to see what the makeup of
that Coalition is when you and I spoke
yesterday morning I spoke about the rise
of a far-right politician known as
itamar Ben gavier he and the pro Zionist
party that he is a part of
um have polled extremely well overnight
and it is looking like that he might
have a very senior position in any
future Israeli government which would
see a massive Lurch to the right of
Israeli politics
Aleister many thanks
uh General bolsonaro has broken his
silence almost two days after losing
Brazil's presidential runoff election
now while not directly conceding defeat
he stopped short of contesting the vote
the leftist former president Lula de
Silva will return to power after winning
by a razor thin margin
want to start by thanking the 58 million
Brazilians who voted for me on October
30th as president of the Republic and a
citizen I will continue to fulfill all
the Commandments of our constitution it
is an honor to be the leader of millions
of Brazilians who like me defend
economic freedom religious freedom
freedom of opinion honesty and the green
and yellow colors of our flag
opinion
only as someone who likes to dodge
unnecessary expenditure I'm very unhappy
to report that here is something that I
actually might have to start paying for
it is of course the blue tick on my
Twitter page that is because Twitter's
new owner Elon Musk has announced that
the platforms verified Accolade will be
charged around eight dollars a month
the billionaire says users will get
priority and replies mentions and
searches as well as the ability to post
long videos and audio clips eight
dollars a month I don't think so let's
have a quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the unsettled theme will continue
this week but a change in wind direction
means it will be cooler most places will
have a dry sunny and rather chilly start
but there will be some rain in the windy
West prolonged and heavy for Western
Island that rain will then spread into
the east of islands Northern Ireland and
much of Scotland during the morning with
showers following most other places
staying dry with some sunshine but
whales and Southern England will see the
odd shower it will be cooler with strong
winds bringing severe Gales to many
Western coasts
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
no when the model Heidi Klum hosted her
annual Halloween party her choice of
costume was certainly down to air hey
howdy how are you
uh that was a worm uh Heidi wanted her
way into a party in New York wearing
this she inched her way along the red
carpet saying that she felt like a
million bucks Elon Musk iced tea and
Julia Fox were among the famous faces
who couldn't resist wriggling their way
to the fun rather her than me welcome
back the transport secretary Mark Harper
says that a watchdog report criticizing
police vetting is a wake-up call for
forces in England and Wales speaking to
me earlier I also asked Mr Harper about
the dark conditions at the manston
migrant processing center a problem that
he said wouldn't be solved immediately
it's reasonable to say it's not going to
happen overnight I mean I've been an
immigration minister in the past
um there are no Simple Solutions here
they're very difficult but the
government is putting the steps in place
to procure more accommodation
um you know to start work or to continue
working with our partners in France to
reduce the numbers that are coming
Britain and France could both do more so
what we need to do is work with the
French they do a lot already
we provide resources to help them and of
course people will know that our order
controls uh in France are actually
physically located in France and we've
always worked in close partnership with
French authorities do we think they
could do more yes we could do more as
well and it's about improving that
partnership
as you can see our political correspond
tomorrow coordination morning TC and
again we have a government Minister
making clear that they do understand
that there are significant problems um
but they're not going to be solved
overnight his words no there's a big
effort to get the specific situation at
manston under control we heard from the
immigration Minister Robert generick on
Twitter last night he said thanks to the
hard work and professionalism of the
home office as well as border for staff
and military personnel who they've
drafted in for this he said the numbers
of people the numbers of migrants have
fallen substantially today as in
yesterday and will again tomorrow helped
by the fact that there weren't any
migrant Crossings on the channel
yesterday because of the weather
conditions I understand that at least
hundreds of people were removed from
manston yesterday the capacity though is
supposed to be 1600 so it's not clear
how many uh when they will be able to
get to that because of course it is very
dependent on what the weather does and
whether more people make the crossing in
the meantime
um let's talk shall we uh Matt Hancock
he's been giving an interview to the son
we have a rough idea now of the thought
processes that have gone on inside his
head uh leading him to leave his job in
Westminster and fly to the celebrity
jungle indeed and uh on all the front
pages today uh the former Health
secretary going into the Australian
Outback to eat creepy crawlies and this
is what he tells us and other things
newspaper I haven't lost my marbles or
had one too many pina coladas it's
something I've given a lot of thought to
I was elected by the people and it's
important to engage with voters
especially younger voters no matter
where they are and show The Human Side
of politicians now look talking
something about Hancock's colleagues and
indeed some of the voters in his West
Suffolk constituency they're not
impressed they say when you are a
serving MP it's not the same as if
you're a former politician you should be
there in Parliament participating in
votes and that's why he's lost the whip
perhaps he feels that he's never going
to go back into government and there's
um not you know there's nothing to uh
he's just gonna throw it all throw it
all the way for now but certainly it's
made a big splash and perhaps that's
what Matt Hancock wanted it would be the
most British thing ever if we find this
new sense of national Unity by all of us
funny I'm a celebrity to ensure he gets
absolutely pissed up Tamanna thank you
very much for now um but let's stick
with politics and Boris Johnson remember
him he says he doesn't think Vladimir
Putin would ever use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine and that to do so would
represent a resignation from the club of
civilized Nations this guy's Mark Austin
as this exclusive report
after being forced out of Downing Street
and pulling out of the race to become
leader this is a former prime minister
anxious to cement his legacy and most
notably his support for Ukraine
Putin disastrously
miscalculated we all read his crackers
essay on Ukraine
summer of last year and we could see
that he fundamentally misunderstood what
Ukraine is and it's a total category
error Ukraine is an in a free
independent European culture with its
own identity its own Ambitions its own
destiny but with the invasion not going
Putin's way there are growing concerns
about just how far A desperate dictator
may go do you fear that he could use a
tactical Nuclear I don't I don't think
he I don't think he will I I think he'd
be crazy to to do so
conflict if he did I think what would
happen is that
he would immediately tender Russia's
resignation from the club of civilized
Nations it would be a total disaster for
his country Russia would be put into a
kind of cryogenic economic freeze he
would also crucially I think lose the
patronage of the Chinese and above all
in his own country I think he would
trigger an absolutely hysterical uh
reaction perhaps more comfortable on the
international stage these days he says
he will be attending the climate
conference cop 27 in Egypt even though
Rishi sunak currently is not going I was
invited but I was invited by the by the
Egyptian son see you again and you
presumably think the Prime Minister
should go he's got a massive amount to
do we've got to sort out uh a huge
agenda that's what he's getting on with
but if this is a man still hoping for a
return to Downing Street he's not
admitting it and do you still Harbor
hopes of returning as prime minister is
it unfinished business
Mark you promised this was going to be
about you Chris I I Harbor hopes of
continuing to campaign for uh for
Ukraine and that is my priority and
there are various other things I'm doing
but that is of course it's very dear to
my heart
politics don't always respect ambition
and all the while a desperate war with
desperate suffering goes on
Mark Austin Sky News Central London
Bible here to give us his thoughts on
the nuclear threat hey Mr Bretton Gordon
former head of the British army a
chemical weapons unit Hamish good to see
you again and what do you make of them
Boris Johnson's assessment that Putin
would be crazy to deploy nuclear weapons
in this manner
well I absolutely agree with Boris on
that point it would be unbelievable for
Precinct to use uh tactical nuclear
weapons however Putin keeps doing the
unbelievable so I don't think we can
assume away the fact that he won't use
these sort of weapons after all he
appointed General savaikin General
Armageddon as he's known who I saw very
close are and in Syria over the last few
years now savarkian oversaw Assad using
chemical weapons which kept a sad in
power and all the false flag threats
from Russia about chemical biological
nuclear weapons although it would be
crazy to use them we need to take them
seriously and the talk recently about
dirty bombs
um really is the most important area for
us to focus on because Putin has said
he's going to switch the lights out and
turn off the heating in Ukraine and all
the attacks over the last few days have
really reinforced that
but at the beginning of this war 60 of
that electricity and heat came from
nuclear and only on Monday the Russians
claimed that Ukraine forces had blown up
a landmine in zacharya the largest
nuclear power station uh in Europe which
is ridiculous because the Russian forces
runic so I agree with Boris that
tactical nuclear weapon would be crazy
but
um I am really concerned that the
Russians uh again as the Prime Minister
said are are losing this war
Putin cannot afford to lose it and um
the biggest threat I think is further
turning off of the power and turning off
nuclear power stations which including
Mercedes do and to do that he needs to
blow them up or set them on fire
it just don't in terms of preparing you
know not second guessing you know the
most dangerous man on the planet at the
moment
um and taking them at face values
regarding kind of a dirty bomb how does
one prepare for that I I can understand
that you might ramp up surveillance and
and intelligence gathering to try and
get an early warning of something but in
terms of practical preparations on the
ground what do they need to do the
ukrainians
well first of all the International
Community needs to underwrite and tell
Putin that use of these weapons uh would
elicit a massive conventional response
and our new prime minister has done that
and James Cleveland the foreign section
did that on Monday on Preparation terms
um there's an awful lot you can do and
I'm publishing an app
um which is similar to the one I did for
Ukrainian civilians to tell them how to
survive chemical and biological attack
we're publishing an app on Friday which
tells people how to prepare and what to
do in the event of a nuclear accident or
attack so those are practical things
that you can do because
um you know without without wanting to
terrify people and a lot of people in
this country are terrified and you know
get in touch with me all the time you
know I don't think we need to be
terrified here but with the nuclear
threat higher than it was for most times
in the Cold War it would probably be
sensible to do a few preparations here
as well as you Ukraine but the key thing
is the International Community
particularly NATO particularly ourselves
and particularly Boris because he has
such a huge place in the hearts of the
Ukraine people to make sure that they
know that we're absolutely full Square
behind them and that Putin and you know
his dodgy generals like sabarkin know
that we will not accept them using
nuclear weapons and we can prevent them
using tactical nuclear weapons because
we will get a 24 to 48 hours notice as
they take these things out of their
storage and I hope that our prime
minister and President Biden have told
prison if he moves these missiles and
looks like he's going to fire them we
will take them out so there's an awful
lot we can do I think it needs a lot of
cool calm heads but we must not assume
that he will not use them
um for reasons of time on a very busy
morning I'm afraid we have to leave it
there but always good to have you input
here Mr bright and gone thank you very
much indeed
meanwhile Ukrainian forces are fighting
to push the Russian army back towards
kremlin-controlled territory and Crimea
John Sparks traveled along the road to
Harrison and sent this report
the fields are flat and featureless but
this territory is critically important
for this is the gateway to Harrison City
a regional capital and a military prize
we're looking to our left over there
because that is the direction Russian
forces are in at the moment and it is
open here it it feels exposed
this is the Ukrainian front line some 30
kilometers from the city's outskirts
and we were taken to see the troops who
live and fight in trenches and tunnels
that stretch for miles
sleep that's where you sleep yeah
Alexander says cover is something he
needs this position gets hit every day
um
we found Vadim and Anatoly Manning this
post their eyes fixed on the horizon
and they told us they'll soon recapture
more ground
Winter's coming it's going to get more
difficult isn't it
it's like the first world war down here
it's very compact claustrophobic really
people
sleeping in holes in the walls
their personal effects
are tucked away in little cubby holes
when people talk about living in close
quarters this is a good example of it
there is a machine gun post that
protects Ukrainian positions and the
local Commander offered to take us there
it occupies ground the ukrainians have
recently seized but the Russians are not
very far away you know this trench was
dug by the Russians so they know exactly
where it is
at the end of a shallow trench we found
a pair of Gunners imagine
he said they were facing troops from the
Russian region of chechnya
um
the light was fading and we were told to
return an order given with good reason
the area was shelled with clouds of dust
rising in the fields
the smoke to the east
the smoke to the South
the after effects of artillery shells or
mortars
I think it's going to be a
a long night for these guys
John Sparks Sky News in the region of
Harrison
let's return a note to the dire
conditions at the manston migrant
processing center in Kent we're joined
on the program by the former Chief
immigration officer for the Border force
and Cali Kevin Saunders Kevin great to
have you in the program this morning and
what is your view of what has been
happening at manston was this all too
predictable or is it a situation as
described by the government where those
increasing numbers coming across the
channel took them by surprise causing
the overcrowding issues
good morning yes I I think you're you're
right there I think you did take them by
surprise nobody expected uh to have a
petrol bomber on Sunday uh hurling
petrol bombs at the facility in Dover
clearly they the people there had to be
moved rapidly and Manchester was the
only place so uh that that was a
surprise but there was nothing more they
could do so that took the figures up to
about 4 000 there they've moved people
out now but that that was uh that wasn't
good
speaking though to the Chief Inspector
of presidents who went to manston back
in July and has been monitoring events
since then it seems pretty clear that
there have been identifiable issues with
the site for much longer than just the
past few weeks when we've seen numbers
Rising I mean just in terms of the
facility itself in your view is it
currently fit for purpose
well um the chief instructor's report
wasn't brilliant but Roger Gayle will
open B said some of the things they're
doing they're a very good he highlighted
the food and the medical facilities as
being first class
okay so so but but clearly a set of
circumstances in which people are being
detained for longer than 24 or 48 hours
in a facility designed only to house
them for that length of time a facility
that doesn't have any beds that is
restricted access to fresh air that has
people using toilets with the doors open
for security reasons that doesn't sign
to me like a facility we should be
praising from the rafters but to
thereafter no no I quite agree with you
it's it's not it's not good at all and
you're right it was only meant to be a
holding facility
it's all 24 hours
um there seems to be a bit of a
bottleneck with getting people out of
manston into hotels
yeah we keep hearing from from the
government in the most general of Tams a
desire to sort out the situation in the
channel itself and frankly I'm sure the
British public on the whole do not want
people risking their lives particularly
younger people kids involved risking
their lives crossing the channel but but
they've had 12 years to have a go at it
and so far no one has come up with a
bright idea capable of stopping the
traffic is it simply the case that
unless we set up safe routes to apply
for Asylum here in the UK people will
continue to take this as the only option
available
people will continue to take this
um forever even if you set up so-called
safe routes
because not everybody is going to
qualify for a safe route therefore the
people that don't qualify will try and
come across the channel so forget that
one it doesn't work
what we need to do is to get some sort
of working agreement with a friend
for them to patrol the channel in boats
along with our guys on the channel and
actually return all the people that I've
tried to come across back to France
Kevin saw this we have to leave it there
many thanks for your time
now as of next Monday bird owners across
England will be required by law to keep
their Birds indoors let's hope the move
will help slow the UK's largest outbreak
of avian flu Steve Childress is a turkey
farmer who's been forced to Cull his
flock of ten thousand and he joins us on
the program Steve it's good to talk to
you about the circumstances in which
we're talking and I'm sure for you
pretty horrific just describe what
you've had to do on the farm
so basically going back to a couple of
weeks ago we
um obviously had some birds dying
um we got them looked at by a vet who
then told us to get on to defra we had
defra out here uh who tested the birds
um we then got
um diagnosed with bird flu and within a
couple of days
um they're all moving in here with the
um culling facilities and yeah over the
next those next two days everything was
cold
I mean like the emotional and mental
stress of it all is just incredible
um yeah you just can't describe it it
was just awful I'm I'm very sorry to
hear that so of course that means your
Christmas tree this year is entirely is
entirely done is there any Prospect of
you being in a position next Christmas
to start earning off trackies again yeah
so the problem we've got going forward
is is basically
um we've got to now have all these
buildings around here uh empty for 12
months
um and we can't touch it we can't clean
them out so we normally restock in June
um of next year but obviously we now
can't restocked until October so on the
way things are standing currently that
we won't be able to uh stop again for
next year either
um so we're potentially going to miss
this Christmas and next Christmas
um so it's going to be three Christmas
before you actually sell any more birds
from here which is obviously financially
is obviously devastating for us and it's
not you know it's obviously not only us
there's like the egg producers there's
the broiler chickens or everyone's
getting affected by this
um you know it's it's a massive problem
that needs to be dealt with
um either you know there needs to be a
vaccine or a way that we can move
forward with our businesses
um and yeah I mean you know it's the I
don't think people realize how how big a
problem this actually is at the moment
and it's obviously getting worse by the
day
Steve just just briefly I first noticed
there was a problem with the evening
through several months ago when I went
on a trip back to Scotland my part of
Ayrshire walking along the beach
hundreds of dead guillermots were washed
up there was barely a mention of it in
the Press at the time and there was
certainly nothing coming from government
I'm just wondering whether or not we
have been perhaps slow to identifying
the scale of this avian flu outbreak and
how difficult it's going to be
absolutely I mean these birds I mean the
flu is not not left at England this year
like it normally does it normally leaves
and then it seems to come back in the in
the winter but this year it's been here
the whole year round and you know it's
been ongoing in the background on the
back burner but I mean the area that
we're in obviously Norfolk here I mean
if you look on the map it's just been
absolutely decimated and it's you know
it's just by the day there's there's new
cases and it's like say it's spreading
across the country I mean we've we've
since our birds have gone
but we are literally in the last 15
seconds of the program I really
appreciate your time we'll keep your
fingers crossed for the farm
no problem thank you